yet another carrot eating Peter Jackson
cameo these assassins are terrible at
sneaking up on their victim or were they
hired by the real assassins to serve as
decoy assassins maybe I should introduce
myself I'm Amber's dad though
unnecessary flashback is unnecessary you
are the heir to the throne of Dorian man
does anyone in middle-earth do anything
at all without Gandalf putting the idea
in their head is middle-earth just
Gandalf's personal life-sized dollhouse
beneath the feet of a fire-breathing
dragon I can't stress enough how much
light this conversation sheds on the
events we saw in the first film it's
zero
you could maybe try calling the Eagles I
mean it can't gotten too far away since
they just dropped you off a little bit
ago here's another reason the books
don't matter when the filmmakers can't
insert just one sentence explaining why
the Eagles could only take them so far
and that's all it would have taken it
will help us all people killers
why does Gandalf waste time acting like
the bear beast thing is Bayon the owner
of the house they decide to go to in
order to seek refuge from the bear beast
thing you know what would have really
helped in this situation someone who
knows magic none of the other Dwarfs saw
this oh good more fleshed out villain
characters that either barely appear in
the book or aren't in the book at all
awesome that probably won't add to the
bloat at all also this bold guy is a
discount a sog he looks exactly like a
zombie with metal in his flesh oh no man
I'm off it may be blind in one eye Bjorn
answers a softball question in a vague
manner so that Bilbo has to clarify what
the hell he meant by that could the
darkness lies upon that forest this
pretty much should go without saying in
middle-earth by now right
is there a forest that doesn't have some
sort of darkness lying upon it
I don't like dwarves they're greedy but
I usually save such opinions until I've
already been a good host by serving food
and drink to them is there no way around
middle-earth uses miles for distance
measurement
we interrupt this unnecessary Hobbit
sequel to bring you the lost world
Jurassic Park oh come on
how did Bilbo get access to his sword
after being spun into a cocoon I mean
look at this does this look like
something anyone would be able to move
their arms and legs around in also Bilbo
would have had to have easy access to
his sword to be able to unsheathed that
while inside a cocoon and he clearly
didn't have it out when he got caught in
the web
fortunately for Bilbo the spiders
dragged all the dwarves to one place
before eating them making them easier to
rescue because everyone knows spiders
prefer to eat family-style nearly every
spider has to go check and see what that
noise was it's also fortunate that there
are all these layers of spider web to
catch each of the falling dwarves and
ease them to the ground especially
considering the spider that Bilbo just
stabbed fell down and hit the ground
hard oh come on that thing fell and
bouncing has definitely lost forever if
you're gonna say the ring wants to be
found because it has a mind of its own
then it shouldn't ever fly out of his
control in the first place oh look
Legolas is in this movie is Batman in it
too or double-oh-seven it's my wee lad
Gimli
you know from Lord of the Rings the
popular series of books and movies we
are witnessing the George Lucas if
occasion of Peter Jackson with these
Hobbit movies there's no doubt about it
it always is aren't you going to search
me who could have anything down my
trousers
that's a pickup line I have not tried
but I'm going to now oh good because
she's fucking hot also why does Legolas
given that this dwarf is staring at her
does he know that this very unlikely elf
dwarf love story is about to happen
I tell them he could go îsh kakhfê Aon
dog North how is an elf supposed to do
that why do you linger in the shadows
toriel is hiding from view for no reason
so that we could have this manufactured
suspense moment good there are always
unguarded gates out there unlikely elf
dwarf love story sometimes tonight good
god this movie is two and a half hours
and now we know why empty bottles should
have been sent back to esker off hours
ago
the bargeman will be waiting for them
Bilbo shows up at the exact moment the
elves talk about the barrels and where
they go and luckily they were speaking
English and not elvish obviously there
aren't theme-park water ride action
sequence is this the unguarded gate that
Bull was talking about because this is
heavily guarded in fact it takes all of
them getting distracted by Bilbo and the
dwarves in order for the orcs to make an
attack were the orcs expecting this bold
yells after them and there are instant
works waiting for the dwarves downriver
wait a minute that sounds like Kili
falling into a barrel also this orc has
to ground just before killing her and
stabs at nothing in particular
staple sword oh good this work had an
axe exactly the tool I'll need later
when we chop a log everyone with an axe
has the current carrying their barrel to
the exact spot they need to make this
happen
also the B team of orcs were really
heavy on axes weren't they when we saw
the battle start most of them at Soler's
bows and arrows maybe a mace but axes
didn't come into play until the dorbz
needed them everything this sequence is
and stands for
these dwarves had a spare barrel
floating down the river with them and
were able to keep it around just in case
this should happen movie wants to have a
sense of danger in some moments but in
other moments do this or grazes his cue
sword twice to kill Legolas so that
thorn can kill the orc
so you're telling me the toriel was
running toward Legolas saw this orc and
measure her shot so that she could
deflect his arrow also how convenient is
it that she pulls off this badass shot
instead of killing him since Legolas
wants to keep this Orgel I've anyway
discount inigo montoya a shadow that
grows in the dog how much of this movies
run time is devoted to veiled references
to surah at weed roots at least 20
minutes we were tracking a company of 13
dwarves no 13 the black-haired Archer we
stuck him with a Morgul shaft there is
no reason why this work would make
mention of Kili other than to distress
Toria but this work doesn't know about
that love story so this is completely
pointless well we assume she didn't
return or else this story would be
stupid come on now that I see turn out
your bucket because you all surely have
loose change in there after all this
you've been through in the last movie in
this one
Hayley yeah not so fast
yet another bullsh falls conflict that
bogs this movie down to a nearly 3 hour
run late it seems like these guys have
dumped enough fish to see some dwarves
but when Alfred tells the guys to stop
it looks like no fish have been dumped
out of the barrels at all they'd be in a
dome by trapping like us then we must
find these troublemakers there was a
huge pause in the conversation while the
master got up walked out of his bedroom
and halfway down the stairs before
responding Stephen Colbert won Tom
Bombadil zero human Rube Goldberg
messaging system cute scene but how the
fuck did they know where to swim to get
here how did Bilbo in the doors jump
into the water without being seen
wait does this family directly into the
lake my big dwarves climbing out of our
toilet that's racist King beneath the
mountain
to resolve the prophecies man Dwarfs
tears also armory has a convenient open
windows so that people can steal from it
how many weapons does this guy need to
carry couldn't they just pass them down
to the stair dwarves outside and make a
quiet pile after arrow he shoots each
one missin its mark these assholes make
it sound like shooting a flying dragon
is easy I speak to the master of the men
of the lake what do you see the prophecy
fulfilled the prophecy that mentions the
league being set on fire sure what the
hell right this horn will help us why
will no one help you everyone in this
town loves dwarves now the desolation of
Smaug roll credits please to read a
drawn sleigh what really it takes keen
eyes to spot a maze pattern pillar that
reaches up to the top of the mountain
I've lost you tonight there's no more
bull we walked all this way and nearly
died a million times give me the fucking
key and I'll drag it along the rock
until it hits a keyhole how is this
asshole been breathing underneath a
mountain of gold the whole time the
Arkenstone is conveniently 24 feet from
where Bilbo is standing in a great
underground Kingdom the size of
Minneapolis
oh come on how do these assholes know
bard would be running through here
Laketown is a twisty nightmare of
directions and they were hiding out here
for whatever reason holy Sh Gandalf's
gonna need a lot of eagles to get out of
this Jam also Sauron bitches out instead
of killing Gandalf when he has the
chance
Bilbo seriously says out loud the one
weakness the dragon has and is out of
this world fortunate the dragon didn't
hear it properly again the Arkenstone
magically finds its way to an area right
next to Bilbo
so here's boffer looking for kingsfoil
which we remember him going out to get
20 minutes ago in movie time
and it's perfect timing because the orcs
see him and know which house to attack
here's the problem when boffer first
started looking for this weed Bard was
still in his house since that time bard
runs out gets captured the orcs arrived
much later and this asshole is just now
finding kingsfoil and since bard says we
feed it to the pigs this should have
taken like five minutes at most to find
dammit elves do you ever arrive before
an attack maybe if they were fewer than
13 of these dwarves I might actually
care that one of them is about to die oh
now we see why it took so long for
buffer to get the kingsfoil
it's so that she elf could save handsome
dwarf and serve the love story also if
toriel doesn't show up how do they
expect to use the king's foil it looks
like it requires a lot of chanting and
special elf leg rubbing and glowing
dragon that can smell the warms even
when they're outside the mountain can't
smell them when they're right underneath
them
eons old dragon is fooled by the old Hey
look over here gag it's almost like they
wrote the script for the dwarves to
escape and then design the set to match
Jesus it's like the world's most
elaborate dragon escape system built
centuries in advance of its being needed
oh no I sure hope Legolas lived through
this oh wait he's in fellowship so this
is a pointless bit of fluff by a
resistant fire escaping rope how I
smiled not affecting this rope in any
way this sheer size should tangle the
series of ropes coming down this shaft
and thus effect thorns descent also use
your fire dude or why not just cut the
rope with your talons make him fall to
his death here's this trick I learned
where I can balance a dwarf on my mouth
the only problem is it takes me a really
long time to kill anything while I'm
doing it
oh sure now use your fire there's no
fire hot enough to set them ablaze who
knows I don't know if you do or not
seems like smog only uses his fire when
it's pointless but I'm sure you'll find
a way to make him use it for the plot
[Music]
that's not how fire works one furnace to
light them all after years and years
everything still works in this place how
is a river of molten gold not melting
this makeshift boat made of regular
metal and even if it shouldn't be
melting it shouldn't it be heating the
out of it making it impossible for
thorne to ride without getting
third-degree burns and fire use your
fire sure was lucky the dwarves were
working on a giant gold statue way back
in the day as this bull wouldn't smiled
it breathed in a bunch of molten gold
can't be good for the system by taking
it out on people who are not you we
interrupt this very short stories
unnecessary second installment to bring
you a cliffhanger ending and a year-long
wait for the rest of the story oh and
also you
sounds delish
let me just toss some genes and in a
tweet a minute who is this
[Applause]
oh that sounds like a pig fainting
we are look like a lame smile night
gelfling maybe you're guessing
it's about you something you carry
something made of gold
I love gold the look of it the taste of
it the smell of it the texture I love
God so much that I even lost my
genitalia in an unfortunate smelting
accident
[Music]
you can't look you right that's a fact
yes they get confused and the wires get
crossed you got to look like good chin
like it looks like I'm looking at you
when I'm looking at you Chanti buddy the
important thing you guys got keeping
behind this is that these things gossip
they get together and they gossip they
are very worried by the way so you got
to be very careful with these little go
safety is first all right on somebody
with tranquilizer gun ready to knock
this proud the thing is this is their
gift okay they're built to be thrown
like a lawn dart they're top-heavy like
a lawn dart - they're built for accuracy
oh my god this is it can we bowl with
this guy
brother Robbie's brothers the bowling
ball no the the brother you put a
skateboard on him he strapped into a
skateboard you toss him down an alley at
some pins no we don't know a thing about
each other I don't know where we're
meeting I don't even know your name I
know you're an army doctor you've been a
delivered home from Afghanistan and
they've got a brother who's worried
about you but he won't go to him for
help because he didn't approve of him
possibly because he's an alcoholic
likely because he recently walked out on
his wife and I know that your therapist
thinks your limps psychosomatic quite
correctly on the frame it's enough to be
going on there do you think the name
Sherlock Holmes and the address is 221b
Baker Street afternoon